day four of the US Open gets underway
this morning in New York City as elite
tennis players battle for a Grand Slam
victory six time US Open singles
champions Serena Williams dominated the
court last night setting up a third
round matchup with her older sister
Venus tomorrow this year is the 50th
anniversary of the tournament in the
open era US Open champions past and
present tell us in their own words about
the challenges and triumphs that
distinguish this competition
[Music]
you've got to be versatile you got to be
able to adjust the conditions could be
rain could be humidity wind day session
night session the crowd the pressure you
got to be tough find that actually gear
when you really need
you have the will to win it looks so
easy doesn't it you have to Train tennis
is a great microcosm of life
but this being the 50th anniversary of
the US Open no one really knows what
that means
Arthur Ashe winning the 1968 the very
first open here being the first
african-american male to win a major
right here in the United States of
America I'll never forget Arthur on the
court with his dad after the match
winning the 2017 US Open is probably the
best memory of my life an American
player at the US Open is obviously
incredibly special so just go with
matches there let alone win is
incredible my favorite thing about the
US Open
the fans
i won the junior competition there in
2004 and that was a huge moment for me
and I loved had some of my family there
[Applause]
it's the biggest tennis stadium we have
in the world of tennis 23,000 people
when the stadium gets filled up in the
night session it's really quite unique
[Music]
in New York City I know I'm biased I'm
in the greatest city in the world but I
got to tell you something there's
nothing like the energy here fantastic
backhand down the line such a buzz
that's it's awesome New York rowdy man I
love it here it's not about us
just about the fans without the fans
it's nothing New York is great for
something to happen and when you ignite
the fire they're all out and I love that
about him that was great yeah
we're never there I know absolutely